[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
pregame picks
i am your host pierre p with the plug
and i'm joined by my main man famous
lost as always and this is the show
where you
the people at home can win free cash
prizes by simply predicting the random
[ __ ] that goes on
in a nba pregame lois what's crack are
you ready to give away some money
i'm ready pete i'm ready you look good
today too you look good today
hey thank you i'm ready too man we
raising the stakes giving away a lot of
money so let's get to these picks baby
yes sir let's get it
what's topping dog famous i'm in the
building
let's get it boom i told you how crazy
is that he's showing off the money with
this look
we always keep it clean step first wow
my name is i told y'all welcome to
pregame pics let's get it
my boy lois we back at it again what's
going on my brother how you been i ain't
seen you in a week talk to me before we
dive into this man what's going on with
you
man i feel good man we that's a long
time man i've been ready to get back up
here though man i miss you
pause i miss you man no man i i miss you
too pat bailey they say we gotta we we
got a crazy chemistry seth curry
pac-man and like i said earlier
hey okay hey don't don't get me started
but like i said earlier
we're raising the stakes we're giving
away a lot of money so let's
see these picks can we pull up the
prompt please and see what we got today
we live
in milwaukee lois you know i'm closer
than walking i'm in chicago man
the windy city oh you don't know nothing
about this type you're gonna need a
bigger coat than that you need
you need a bigger coat than what you got
on about yeah yeah this
this ain't doing me no justice but first
and foremost we have who will make 15
shots first
in the warm-ups giannis or zion
williamson again those are who will
make 15 shots first we only count in the
makes and then secondly
we have make or miss the final shot of
the bucks warm up
will it be a make or miss los
let's let's emphasize this i want you to
understand we're giving away a lot of
money
if that first one is right we giving
away 500
we never done it again five people we'll
be going home with 500
if we can get that one right the first
one now before we dive into these pics
lose
i do want to tell the people at home
that like last episode
we're going to pick as a family we're
going to win as a family and we're going
to lose as a family
so they got to be active in those
commons now what you thinking for this
first one
the race to 15 because you you you're
the main man with the with with the plan
we going with zion giannis who gave them
15 shots
first talk to me we watched we watched
zion make 18 before i think so we
watched lion make 18
or or he was like one under 18 something
like that
he was like one under 18. so we're doing
15 now
this is going i'm going with zion so the
question is who is going to get the 15
first yes first first
zion first priors
okay so you're going with zion now
listen i'm not mad at your pick we in
this together we have family just like
everybody else watching at home
my main thing los is the last time we
did this
zion did get a little sexy on us and it
took him a while to get to his
his mix he was being cool they had him
feeding the pulse
we know he don't even do that [ __ ] in
the game don't know why they had him
doing it
but he was doing it we know giannis is
the mvp he cut
he ain't throwing the ball to the post
he he's shooting at that hey i do
look i will never do this again in my
life i would never do this again in my
life but i changed my mind
everybody we are a family go with gigi
go with gigi i am picking gg
well okay so be picking jeezy everybody
at home y'all diving those comments
let us know if you rocking with me and
lois we rocking with gg
lost is my man 100 grand so when he says
go with me
if he rocking on rolling that's how we
going now listen
listen we won't start counting the makes
for everybody at home until they both on
the floor we ain't doing out of that
[ __ ] with one guy been on the court
10 minutes prior
and he got a head start they both got to
be on the court they both got to be
at the same time and that's how we
rocking you know what i'm saying now
listen while the people at home los
is is commenting their thoughts and
their decisions
who are you starting the team with i saw
that trending
earlier on twitter today and in the
comments a little bit while we was
getting ready
they were discussing zion or giannis who
you starting to franchise when i had to
ask you
i'm dying to hit his hands look you got
a two-time
mvp and they both they both young man so
so it's they both kind of guard big man
they kind of guard big man
but but but i i i'm going with zion and
don't kill me
i'm going with zion there's no limits
inside listen
i'm i'm not i'm not i'm not killing you
you know why because i'm glad you picked
zion i thought you were just going to go
go giannis because he was a two-time
mvp but i don't think that mattered
because at the end of the day
when you're building that franchise you
want that jewelry and janice ain't got
it yet to give him no edge
what does he have to do to get better
gigi is always look look i think zion is
gonna get better
uh he can he's gonna work on his jumper
he's gonna work on his jump a little
more he might not be making a lot of
threes
but he's gonna be making the 17 feet
gigi i hate to say this but i think gg
is maxed out
he's i don't think he's gonna be a
better shooter and stuff like that
because
it's hard it's it's hard look it's hard
to start working out to be better
when you're already a two-time mvp why
would i be working on some more stuffs
more stuff
when i'm the mvp of the league doing
what i'm doing right now
so it's kind of you know you know you
know some different mindset
only person will keep getting better is
kobe
but now listen i just i just did get
word that the comments are leaning to
giannis they rolling with us
y'all make sure y'all at home keep
commenting and letting us know
zion or yon is first of 15 me and my boy
los
we favorite and giannis listen to us
because the male the man low's got it on
lock with these picks ain't gonna lie
he he look his jump shot a little
suspect
he may not know how to match his colors
right but he got a thing with them
picks he know how to pick them i ain't
gonna lie i give credit with this man
you wear one good jacket you wear one
good jacket and now you want to start
talking jokes please stop it
please stop it hey hey check me out i'm
i'm holding it down man i'm holding it
down
listen now low so you were talking about
the jump shot [ __ ]
i wish i wish that they had the clip
that i sent you on twitter in my jump
shot and we could show giannis how he
need to tweak his [ __ ] so he can start
going in like man cause my [ __ ] bought
her
my [ __ ] rolled out for you boys didn't
show my jumper didn't show my jumper
didn't show my [ __ ]
then watch yours but you know no you
you're a guard you're a girl you're
supposed to have it you know what i'm
saying i'm a guard too but yeah this is
closer to my height
so you know man you know what i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
but listen you sick basketball what are
you talking about
loads i'm coming basketball is sad we
heard you got a hamster
i want the people yes in the comments to
help you name
help you name this hamster because you
told me you haven't found a name yet
no i was going you're wrong you're
rocking with that back
yeah i like that though i like that i
like it help me out y'all help me pick a
name for my hamster i was going with
shinee
but help me help me think of something
y'all
that's a it's a girl it's a girl you
you all right so that's important to
know so this is a new one check them out
check them out
check them out check them out pete
what's that how crazy
what the hell he going don't stop now he
know the camera
don't stop now don't know what to do
jeans you tell my agent now that mo
you know what that is i'm going to type
to the murder boy tightening
hugging that boy go crazy go crazy
go casey now check him out
oh he's stupid oh he's stupid hey let me
chill
let me tell before i found out he got he
got part ownership in the pelicans or
something
let me tell you i only know what that is
like you you look like you dance like
that you look like you dance like that
don't disrespect me like that bro i
don't dance [ __ ] like that i got it
you kind of look like a little baby too
from chicago that's my boy you kind of
look like that
was a little bit bigger for the west
side of chicago i heard a lot you know i
hit a lot
one two you know you know what i'm
saying
i got something
come on man don't chop me okay don't
drop me hey load them comments up
let us know what y'all want lois to name
his girl
pet hamster i know lot's like me we're
from the hood i ain't never had
no hamster before are you ready for that
responsibility yeah
dude i had two hamsters one time i went
to the club came back home from the club
had seven hamsters i thought the dude
was a big dude
come to find out it was a woman and she
was pregnant
bro somebody said left out
that step back said left that are you
feeling left out
no no what i
ain't gonna lie bro your name is already
a one the shenanigans i don't know if
they get that reference or they know
where that's from but i'm rocking with
your name
oh yeah yeah yeah they don't know
they don't know about today they all
know nothing about
like that but she's latina so she don't
know nothing about no shenanigans i
tried to make her watch martin
and she won't she she didn't like it you
know i was mad as hell
you know somebody said giannis yo yo
shorty ain't like
martin come on now come on little shorty
i can get it together
two seconds i was two seconds i was two
seconds for letting me go
m-c-a-a uh production
the dude who said emcee hamster make
sure he don't win no money
that was that was a terrible name x him
out for winning money i don't
hey why are you acting out why are you
doing no money why you playing why you
playing that's catchy as hell
emcee hamster that's catchy as hell i
like that i love it
that's what i'm saying i don't like the
corn in this man i like shane nate shane
ain't number one nobody in the comments
saying nothing that i'm feeling
somebody said left out i don't know what
left that has to do with your hamster
but here we go we finally got our guys
coming to the court
the new orleans pelicans are on the
floor we got the camera on zion look at
okay he's looking he's looking fierce i
think carolina boys
them carolina boys walking out at the
same time though shout out carolina
shout out we gotta go we got a strong
and we got them linky
hey for those of y'all that may be just
tuned in or forgot
we're now waiting for giannis to hit the
floor challenge one does not
start until giannis and zion are both on
the court we ain't giving nobody no head
no head start first to 15. we rocking
with
you there we go hey and i just got word
the family pick is giannis they trusting
us lost
they going with giannis let's go let's
go let's go family come on
i want to see excitement in the comments
if you voted for giannis and you rolling
with us i want to see excitement
hey you should be ready to get some
money that's one
that's one add it up add it up that's
one they only stay on the corner at the
same time that was the layup
it count okay it counted we dropped it
in look we dropped it
zombies started started yet
look he's shooting come on all right
that's p p where you what's up where you
vip
you being la fitness are you being 24
you being will you be hooping it
oh my god i'll be hooping i'll be
hooping everywhere but since the
pandemic here
all that [ __ ] ain't really been open so
we've been writing out this gym
uh called a mac we call it the mac it's
over here by me but
normally um i'll be at export i'll be at
my local export giving out buckets shout
out to
gg got two uh will you be out with it
yeah hey we gonna have to link bro
we're gonna have to lincoln hoop
yeah sean you know shut up my boy man
sean was talking about chicago said i
gotta come to the y in the la fitness
whatever they got
up in chicago so you know i got to come
out there and show love in chicago i
never hooped
in la fitness or 24 something like that
in chicago i hoped aau back in the days
but not
not since i've been older so
you shouldn't want your jersey hanged in
la fitness i'll be seeing who'll be
hoping
i'm cooking wherever i'm at i'm cooking
i'm cooking whoever wherever i'm at
that that [ __ ] ain't about nothing but
listen when it when the world opened
back up
zion got the lead but i mean uh giannis
got the lead back
when the world opened back up we got it
we got a link man i'm telling you we got
a link
you can and i'm gonna put this out on
the table right now you could be on my
team
or you can get you a team and we're
gonna whip y'all ass
hey i'm i'm giving you the chance right
the three one gigi
gigi's gonna hit a three so gg is
definitely gonna win
two i'm gonna you don't wanna play my
boys you don't wanna play my boys i'm
telling you right now you don't wanna
play my five
i'll play your five i i i'm locked in in
the league i get some real hoopers on
your ass
what are you talking about i got i got i
got that you don't want to do that i got
me bronze steph
james harding no matter yeah we ain't
doing that
i want to play against regulars i want
to i want to bust y'all less
but my boys my boys ain't regular and
i'm not reckless
hey can we get a rewind of giannis i
don't think lowe's keep them
oh my god hey we about to send some
people home if giannis dances like that
we bout to assist people home with 500
if you was rocking with giannis get
ready get ready
five people gonna be sent home with 500
we never done like nothing like that
ever before on this show
again we doing things new we picking as
a family and we're winning or
losing as a family y'all tell us what
y'all want in the comments
whatever side y'all leaning to is the
one we're gonna rock with and then hey
if we lose
we lose but if we win we're picking five
of y'all to take
home cash that's a new way we doing
pre-game picks
so listen zion is stretcher i don't know
if that's a pause on it or not but
matter of fact i don't give a damn no
pause
no pause no ain't no polls ain't no
pause that's cheating
uh cool i just got word it's still on
y'all giannis can ramp it up come on
giannis don't get sexy and cool on us
now gg
this is the part i hate this gg stop
shooting jumpers gg shooting jumpers and
[ __ ] what's wrong with him
hey hey lois walk us through this
stretch
whenever the camera get on zion please
walk us through that stretch
i don't understand that [ __ ] wait is he
stretching now hey i ain't never let me
just get a shot of that
real quick a quick a quick one two of
zion just two seconds
giannis just missed another jumper oh
he's putting it back never mind
he he know he must have heard he's about
to be the gym he must hurt me he bout to
be the janitor
he okay he must
no i don't stress like that bro if i if
i was stretching back in the days i have
a 40 right now stupid did i'll be
i'll be out there warming up with gg
i would be out there warming up with him
but i told him i ain't want to play
cause i wanted to do this with you
cause i'll rock with you that hard i
turned down the nba to do pregame picks
for sure
hey i'm a real one what can i say same
thing how did this hey what'd you eat
today why would i want to work out every
day
huh what you eat today yana's got 10 by
the way
yeah hey y'all just blowing this out the
water tell me what you ate today y'all
just got this in the bag
look at this zion zion think it's a joke
sign
talking this [ __ ] is all right up there
playing around
they about to get beat by 40. now they
both get beat by 40 brother
that's why i changed my that's why i
changed my because i remember zion from
last time
listen we gonna start keeping track of
me and los
when we writing when we wrong so y'all
know the history and y'all can know when
we doing the pre-pre-production introdu
introduction whatever when we making our
my our points on who y'all should rock
with
rock with us cause five people are now
about to go home with five
hundred dollars we two shots away yada's
just dunk it
i don't want no coming back just duck it
yeah see he talking have a conversation
trying to take this [ __ ] again
they think this is a game what the hell
they got going on like i knew i knew
that i knew gg was gonna take it serious
cause zion did the same [ __ ] last time
talking and stuff i told you because i
did the last time i told you
family 15 yeah yes
15. we bought it again listen right
again
when me and lo speak follow suit
follow suit now we got five people going
home with
five hundred dollars again we ain't
never done this much
ever i told y'all we was raising the
stakes and now five people going home
with 500
we're gonna be making our uh picks for
the winners and a few
so i hope y'all was active in those
comments because i really want some of
y'all to go home with that 500
hopefully it ain't the dude who said m.c
hamster i
ain't no hater but god that's my guy
brother that's my guy
that's my guy give him 250 give him 250.
next up give him 250. next up we got
make or miss
buck's final shot we're giving away more
money we ain't done
look at us blessing the folks y'all
thought it was over because we was
giving 500
away but we not done yet we're not done
lost again talk to me is it going to be
a make or miss for the bucks final shot
you're the master at this hey i'm gonna
give you credit look look this is tough
this is tough but i'm going by i'm going
by how the world is shifting right now
they they don't lost full game straight
and they they just they
out of whack right now i would i would
normally say they gonna make the last
shot because they're nba team but
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say
they're gonna miss this one
i got a whole explanation now before we
before we die
before we dive in this one because again
i trust what you're saying
wait we got our winners here we go can
we we about to reveal the winners
boom boom boom so we have
halo gram we got we got arnaz williams
i re i remember our neighbors off one on
one y'all if you're old enough you know
one on one
the press who's the played a good time
we got adam you got lauren we got nathan
come on man i do not look like no damn
hardness
yo and we can get a picture of our nes
by the end of the show so people can see
our nails so if you're at home just
google arnaz from one on one
so y'all can see that uh i don't look
[ __ ] like that man but those are five
people that are going home with five
hundred dollars
we not done yet loss is saying that the
bucks is gonna end on a miss
yeah yeah i'm thinking on the missed
the last two times you predicted this
you said it was gonna be a make because
they're gonna lay it up or they're gonna
dunk it and you was right
so in my heart i'm feeling like the same
thing could happen here
somebody gonna dunk that and it's gonna
be a make i gotta
i got a weird feeling some weird [ __ ] i
got a feeling somebody gonna be walking
away and throw a shot up
and it's gonna miss hey
let us know when i know i know are you
rocking with us with the miss or is it a
make hey who gonna be the one to throw
it up
who gonna be the one to throw it up for
the miss
gg brother that's me and your prediction
that's me and yo okay you going with
yana's brother
i'm gonna go with uh yeah i'm gonna go
brooke lopez i'm gonna go
no no no i'm gonna go he's gonna get a
shot cause he
he ain't gonna play until he got he
ain't gonna play until the last two two
seconds
hey you crazy
you look like you look like lonzo too
that's my cousin you ain't know that
that's my cousin
look at him y'all look at him at the
crib come on man
you can't look like me man to look like
me you man you can't look like me man
it's impossible to look like me i damn
near don't wanna i
no for real i damn that don't want to
have a son cause i don't want him to
look like me
my girl went out man we have a son
you know what i'm saying hey you gotta
be
dj wilson shout out to my boy marcellus
howard that's his mans right there
hey you versus marcellus howard who you
got
hey
yeah i'm posting sale though sale if
you're watching this i'm posting you
oh sale if you're watching this i'm
posting oh yeah
hey we we might have to get that cracker
both of y'all my boys
hey last 50 seconds will the bucks
make it or miss it please flood the
comments let us know right right now
or if you have the commenting we will
see ain't no hat and we're going to win
as a family we're going to lose as a
family me and lois rocking with the miss
hopefully it's a myth so we can send
more people home with money and as
always while we got a quick second
before we get the final result we switch
things up here at pre-game picks it's no
longer early in the day in the bleacher
report app
making pregame picks no everything is
live within the show so you may
must stay here comment be active let us
know what's going on and to my five
winners that are going home with 500
check the bleach report app and check
your dm so you make sure you can get
your money
last 10 seconds lost you ready hey
are we sending more people home with
money i'm ready
hey watch them watch them watch them
watch let's go
let's send some more people home with
money hey come on don't worry about it
don't worry about it
we still going today done shooting y'all
don't worry about the time we see it
it ain't over it ain't over it ain't
over hey ain't nobody
looking good right now boys i'm seeing
the balls look good right i'm sam i'm
i'm seeing bricks i'm seeing gucci mane
all white bricks
oh yeah they bring they're breaking
right now they definitely break
okay come on come on that's that was
that
hold on hold on hold on brick at this
[Applause]
i just got word we still got like two
minutes so we can we can chill
okay they just got me in your head okay
okay cool hey
you you ever seen uh big daddy with adam
sandler
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and she
she say we wasted the big surprise on
you
that's how i feel man they just they
just wasted a big surprise on us had us
thinking we were about to send some more
people home with money
oh yeah they had us looking ahead that's
looking real real real goofy real goofy
up here
that's cool hey that's cool i did have
something to ask you
talk to me kobe they said
you see kyrie said we you see you said
you see kyrie say uh what about kobe
being the um
new the new um nba logo logo
we need that tonight come on man we need
that tonight we need that
we need that yesterday we need that yes
toronto last week last we need that
right now right now immediately oh we're
gonna go and make some changes you know
what i'm saying
no no i mean right now call me brian
right now call me bring back we gotta we
gotta we're gonna make some changes you
know what i said my friend shout out to
kyrie vanessa supported it so we got we
got the first lady
signing off on it we need that
expeditiously and we also need those
nobody ever should be able to wear 24-8
let's just retire that number
across all you got my period you talking
about you talking about period
period that's some bold you know what
that
that's crazy boy yeah that that may that
may be extra because people want to show
love and where to support them so
i'll take that back zach levine with
number eight shout out to my boy making
his first
stop what you think about that are you
are you happy with the all-star uh
selections
uh i'm happy i'm happy i'm so happy for
zach because i haven't seen him drop too
many 50s
not to be in the all-star game and i'm
so happy for bill
from not being in it to start it yep
yes yes yes yes i'm happy it was a lot
of stuff
you know trey ain't making and things
like that but i love i love every
selection and i'm happy for my boy zach
so how does
trey
look watch watch watch watch that's a
miss that's a miss
that's a miss no that's it they're not
done they're not done they're not done
they miss y'all
look wait oh [ __ ] he shot
wait something dumb i told you wait they
told you it was going to be a damn thing
they cheated told you wait wait they
cheated they cheated they cheated
i told you i told you they cheated
i took him man
that's okay my bad hey i hate being
wrong i hate being wrong
hey that's okay because we did we did
send people
earlier away with 500 we sent five
people home without
y'all that's more than i'm sorry you
guys wait
i tried to tell you that's on me that
they was gonna end on a dunk
and sure enough they ended on a dog but
that's okay that's okay we we family we
win together we lose hey what's
what will smith tell uh that's what me
and you is we're the new bad boys
we ride together we got together yeah
bad boys for life yeah
you know what i'm saying you but you you
low-key switch it up in there
you low-key switching sides in there but
but it's whatever you like skiing i
expect i watch with you how about i
switch sides
how about i switch cuz you're talking
about you cuz you're saying you're
saying you said you said cause you saw
so we missed it but i low key
i located i told those i told those
people gonna be a dunk
if you whip me again i'm with you but i
told you
hold on hold on we gotta replay we need
to replay that [ __ ]
look come on man who is that wait i was
trying to look
at the elbow at the elbow i thought the
elbow it looked make sure he's you hey
wait oh [ __ ] i thought he was going to
shoot at the elbow oh he went crazy
that's the start of the show they did
and then that's the starter show then i
can't even
hey lost i can't even enjoy that no more
because we ain't sending the last people
home with them hey
hey hit that hit that hey hit that egg
okay
hit that hit that hey we're gonna see
y'all next week
lois my brother another great
[Applause]
for life
[Music]
you